You know, at some point in time I've been
sort of thinking more and more of one would
hope that
there is going to be some accounting for,
or at least just like the simple realization
that the president of the United States is
not acting like an innocent person and is
not acting like a stable person.
And I mean even from the right, even if they
will continue to defend him as they know that
will, it would be great just to get that acknowledgement
or see them acquiesce to that simple reality.
But regardless of what you think about Donald
Trump's tax policy or what he's doing on trade
or whatever, uh, we are increasingly, uh,
noticing that the behavior that is visible
publicly is not normal.
And the latest exhibit in this is that Donald
Trump burst on Twitter is the best word I
can think of for it.
Tweeting 80 times yesterday, including dozens
already by 11:30 AM Eastern time, mostly about
the FBI impeachment disinflation and lies
in a completely uncontrolled and irrational
way mirroring the hypo manic behavior.
That mental health professional, dr John Gartner
told us about last week.
We've wondered about like what is the process
for Donald Trump tweeting?
Because we know that in some cases he will
dictate his tweets to someone in the next
room, but when there's a dozen retweets and
a half hour or when he is sending tweet after
tweet after tweet, it doesn't seem like that's
happening via dictation to someone in the
next room over.
It seems like this is actually Donald Trump
on his phone like a maniac.
Just tweeting and tweeting and retweeting.
Now, if I were to summarize the 80 tweets
for you, I, it's difficult to do, but I would
summarize them as a combination of insults,
rumors, attacks, unsubstantiated conspiracy
theories and lies.
Uh, maybe with some disinformation thrown
in there, certainly not presidential in any
sense of the word, however it is that you
describe it.
So let's start digging into a little bit of
what went on yesterday.
By 11:30 AM yesterday morning Eastern time,
uh, Donald Trump had already tweeted or retweeted
more than 30 times and it continued all day
reaching 80 tweets, 80 tweets in a day.
I don't pretend to be the busiest person in
the world, but I am way too busy to tweet
80 times in a day.
I have to find a time to make three, four,
five tweets and retweets in combination.
Sometimes I don't even have the time.
Sometimes at 10:00 PM I might send one retweet
out with a comment because I'm so busy that
that's not even possible and I'm not even
really that busy.
This is the president of the United States
and he tweeted 80 times yesterday now to set
up the stage for Donald Trump doing this.
As you may know, as you probably have heard
by now, house Democrats have unveiled two
articles of impeachment, uh, which are actually
being debated right now in the house judiciary
committee as we produce today's program.
And many of the tweets, really almost all
of the tweets are in some way related to that,
other than the occasional tweet bragging about
this, that or the other thing.
So, for example, Donald Trump, a re tweeting
a post about Democrats are running a kangaroo
court, was which was posted by bombed bomb
throwing Congressman Jody Hice, which said
how house Democrats run a kangaroo court.
Ignore the rules, untrue, refuse to recognize
legitimate objections untrue.
And this is how it works.
Steam roll the minority and railroad Donald
Trump, this entire impeachment has been a
farce without any semblance of fairness for
a minority or presidential response.
So there are so many lies here and so many
distortions.
Of course, in general, this is not true in
the sense that house Democrats have followed
the rules that are in place.
Some of those rules were established by Republicans.
They did the closed door hearings correctly.
They've done the public hearings correctly.
This is a farce, generally speaking.
But what you really need to understand here
is that number one, when Jody Heights says
they've done this without a presidential response,
Jerry Nadler invited Trump or whoever he designates
to participate in the judiciary committee
hearings.
They turned it down and of course Republicans
said, well, the participation would not have
been fair because the majority of presses,
the minority do not fall for that.
Okay.
The question is have the rules been followed
because this game that they play, Democrats
play it as well.
Okay.
Whoever is in the minority in the house doesn't
control the agenda in the house, doesn't control
the committees.
That's how it works.
This is how the system is designed and anytime
anything is going on in the house of note,
you will see the whoever is in the minority
party at the time say we are being steamrolled
by the majority.
This is not the way checks and balances are
supposed to work.
This is so unfair, so on and so forth.
This is the way the game is set up.
If it's unfair, the entire system is unfair
all the time.
Even when Republicans as the majority have
used the rules to quote, oppress the minority,
change the rules, many of which Republicans
established.
So this is how they distort and low information
people or just, you know, I'm not saying that
pejoratively.
People who are just busy living their lives
making ends meet, they will see something
like, well, it's true.
I mean, Trump hasn't said anything.
Trump's Trump has to tweet because he can't
go in and participate.
He's been invited and he's turned it down.
Uh, his lawyers have been invited.
They've been directed not to go.
And of course, this entire idea of steamrolling
the minority is a tried and true complaint
that whoever is in the minority position,
we'll, we'll use here.
We have an impeachment, so the stakes are
high.
I understand, but there is nothing unique
about these complaints.
Okay.
Another retweet example, and don't worry,
I'm not going to go through all 80 tweets
like this.
Another retweet example from Congressman Liza
Alden who tweeted with this disgusting impeachment
charade.
I mean, of course it's just, it's just impeachment.
It's a constitutionally enshrined and outlined
mechanism with this disgusting impeachment
charade.
House Democrats have proven themselves guilty
of abusive power and obstruction of Congress.
This is a new line from Republicans.
Last night I did a stream when the house judiciary
was starting the debate on impeachment debate
yesterday.
It was just five minute opening statement
after opening statement.
Um, this is now aligned that they are repeating,
which is the Democrats handling of the impeachment
inquiry is actually the real wrongdoing that
they accused Donald Trump of.
Now, of course, it's not true.
The idea of Congress obstructing Congress
is kind of a weird concept in and of itself.
But more importantly, this is the normal projection
that we're used to seeing.
Republicans do whatever they are accused of.
They simply accuse the other side, Democrats,
uh, Obama, you know, whoever of doing that
exact same thing, Donald Trump also re tweeting
all sorts of other far right figures.
There's one guy named Tom Fitton.
Uh, you can Google him if you're curious,
and many, many others, but it wasn't just
retweets yesterday and Donald Trump tweeting
80 times in one day.
Trump also tweeting things himself.
For example, attacks on other public officials,
riddled with lies.
Quote, shifty Schiff, a totally corrupt politician
made up a horrible and fraudulent statement.
Read it to Congress and said, those words
came from me.
He got caught, was very embarrassed.
Yet nothing happened to him for committing
this fraud.
He'll eventually have to answer for this.
I think the only accurate thing in that tweet
is the correct spelling of Adam shifts.
Last name, despite being called Adam shift
by many people that his last name was correctly
spelled in the tweet and that's all I can
identify.
That is actually accurate.
A shift didn't make up a statement.
He wasn't caught, you know, embarrassed.
This is another calculated strategy from Republicans,
which is go after Adam Schiff.
Why isn't Adam Schiff here testifying at the
house judiciary committee?
We hear that time and time again during the
judiciary committee hitting hearings.
Of course, Schiff is on the intelligence committee,
not the judiciary committee.
Um, when will testify, well, why, why would
Adam Schiff testify in this entire thing?
This is another line that Republicans and
Trump and people around Trump had been repeated.
Where is Adam Schiff?
He's missing, he won't show up.
He's lying.
He's fabricating documents.
He should be investigated and possibly punished.
I'm not going to subject you to all 80 of
Donald Trump's tweets and retweets.
If you're so inclined, you can review them
yourself.
But the highlights are lies and disinformation.
This is not the behavior of an innocent person.
This is not the comportment of a stable person.
Blame anyone but yourself for anything that
you can think of, and again, 80 tweets in
a day, including dozens by 1130 in the morning
when you suspect someone uses uppers and you
see what appears to be a manic hyper use of
social media, certainly, once again, it raises
those questions about what exactly is going
on with Donald Trump.
What I hope people understand is that this
is how Trump has operated his entire adult
business career.
Blame other people, shift responsibility to
somebody else.
Buy or coerce your way out of problems, intimidate
your way out of problems.
Pass the buck whenever possible.
Count on the justice system to work well for
you because you're rich and it usually works
very well for the rich.
This time it's turning out to be a little
bit harder to get away with it because Donald
Trump is president of the United States after
all, but he still might get away with it and
that's the worst part of it.
Eventually, you know, when you look at the
Hollywood movie, the spoiled brat who is mean
and a bully eventually gets held to account
by the little guy, by society, whatever.
Eventually the strong man has a downfall and
the underdog or the people or whatever, uh,
get their day right?
Uh, this is not a screenplay.
This is real life.
And in real life we have two justice systems
and Donald Trump may well end up getting away
with this, the narcissistic, spoiled brat
who in the movies in the great American novel,
whatever, right?
Eventually when you write the story, they
have consequences.
They experienced consequences for what they
do.
This is not a movie.
Our system is not a movie.
It's designed to let the rich, privileged
bullies do whatever they want and very often
get away with it.
Uh, so that is the unfortunate reality that
we are dealing with right now.
Let me know your thoughts about all of this.
If you've been watching the judiciary committee
debate about the impeachment articles, uh,
I am on Twitter at D Pacman.
You can send me a message there.
Please follow me there.
You can also, if you're watching on YouTube,
just leave a reply as a comment remembering
of course to like this video as well.
We'll take a quick break.
We have a lot to discuss today.
I'm glad you're with us.